Dan santis and Gavin Nome are going to
be having their own quasi presidential
debate moderated by Shan Hannity here is
des santis on the debate I think it's an
important debate for the country not
like saying who's better Florida
California because that debate is over
because people have voted with their
feet they've left California and come to
Florida not the other way around he has
lost massive amounts of population no
governor in California history has ever
witnessed population loss at all on net
and he's had it and GRE because it's
because of the policies he's driving
people away uh but what's the future for
the country the future for the country
uh for what the left would want to do is
just double down on the California
policies and so I think it's would be an
important debate I think I mean I think
he's definitely angling for it I think
Biden uh I don't think Biden is going to
step down willingly I think it's harder
to dislodge somebody uh who's an
incumbent president and people assume it
would be but I think the Democrat
establishment really really is concerned
particularly you know if they have to
run against somebody like me I think
that their view on Trump is that he will
help energize their base to come out um
in ways that maybe some other
Republicans won't I'm I don't know that
that's true per se the way they're
thinking it but I do think they think
that I love the way Dan santis gives
that line he goes look look look it was
very trumpy in a way he says look many
Democrats are saying that if you
nominate Trump you're definitely going
to lose because all the Democrats are
going to come out and maybe you know
they're they're more afraid of running
against you know maybe like another
candidate whose name rhymes with like
bong tantis you know I don't look I'm
not saying it I what do I know I'm not
I'm just saying many people are talking
about it okay and it's a good answer and
it's he's absolutely right too about the
debate the debate has already been
settled the u- holes are moving from
California to Florida not the other way
around so the debate is settled Florida
wins that's that's where people want to
live that model of life is better and
that is due in large part to the
policies put in replaced by Ronda santis
so he's won that
debate but my fear
is Will Nome trick
everybody my fear is that good policy
and competence and vision and all the
rest of it don't always win in lowercase
D Democrat
politics sometimes demagogues win
sometimes Hustlers win sometimes Patrick
baitman over there in California wins
and so this is going to be a really good
debate I'm I'm excited for this debate
in that it will have to be substantive
there are no two more different states
in America right now than Florida and
California so even if politicians
especially like Newsome don't want the
debates to be substantive this one will
have to be somewhat substantive it it's
two different Visions for America and
it's going to let us see if Ron de
santis has the Charisma to go toe-to-toe
with a very Charming candidate
n Nome is a perfect test run in this way
in that he is 100% charm 0%
substance
100% slap you on the back make you feel
kind of good 0% effective policies for
government and flourishing and so we'll
see if DeSantis could could beat Nome in
a debate on the day not broadly speaking
which state's doing better but I mean a
debate on the day on TV that could be a
boost to his presidential campaign Now
is it going to bring him from 15% up to
59% where Trump is no it's not in many
ways disantis agreeing to do this debate
is an acknowledgement finally that he is
not in the same tier of candidate as
Donald Trump it's an acknowledgement
that he's not not the front runner even
though some people were describing him
as a potential GOP front front runner
someone who could deal a knockout blow
to Trump that hasn't panned out and what
the disantis campaign has been doing for
for the last couple of months is just
pretending that reality is other than it
is and I thought that was a huge mistake
and it hasn't helped his poll numbers
it's only heard his poll numbers so here
what Dan santis is doing is kind of
risky because he's acknowledging yeah
look I'm not the front runner I'm not
the top I'm I'm the undercard guy and so
I'm going to be in the undercard debate
I'm not going to be debating Joe Biden
that Trump is going to debate Joe Biden
if Biden agrees to do it I'm going to
debate Gavin Nome who's he's the
undercard guy for the Democrats and
we're just going to present our show to
the world
and both of these candidates benefit
from it and Ronda santis stands to
benefit the most though there's also a
fair bit of risk here because if new
beats him then the argument for a dis
sanis candidacy is going to collapse but
good I'm I'm glad that Dan santis is
taking this risk if he continues to play
it safe he's going to go nowhere he's
going to be the he's going to be the
most competent number two or number
three guy in the race he's got to take
bold risks and so he's venturing a lot
here but nothing ventured nothing gained
and it could could be a good show I look
forward to seeing it right now text
nolles to 200 300 for most homeowners
window replacement is not something
they've done before for many it is not
something that they want to do but
something they have to do if you have
put off replacing the windows in your
home because it's too expensive I've got
great news you can now get a free inhome
window consultation and a free price
quote from Renewal by Anderson Renewal
by Anderson's signature service is
committed to giving you the best
customer service possible the best
experience of all supported by the best
people in the industry a superior
process and an exclusive product I have
heard from Carpenters guy wrote in to me
he said Michael I'm a carpenter I heard
you do a read for Renewal and renewa by
Anderson they always have the best
Windows of any houses that I work on
coincidentally I have a cousin who works
for them who's been telling me for years
how great Renewal by Anderson is uh you
can do it right now check it out Renewal
by Anderson it is offering a free inhome
or or virtual consultation UND durable
quality affordable windows or patio
doors for $0 down zero payments zero
interest for one year text nolles kwes
to 200 300 for your free consultation
save 375 bucks off every window and 750
bucks off every door won't last long so
Tex NOS to 2300 nlls to 200 300 texting
privacy policy and terms and conditions
posted at text plan. us texting enrolls
you for recurring automated text
marketing messages message and data
rates may apply reply stop to opt out go
to windowappointment now.com for full
offer details Joe Biden just a few days
ago was at a New York campaign stop and
he told a story about the whole reason
he ran for president in 2020 the whole
reason he's president right now and the
story was that Donald Trump called
neo-nazis very fine people in
Charlottesville and we've heard this
before it it was the very first piece of
rhetoric from Biden's 2020 campaign so
he gets through the Spiel and then about
5 seconds later he just repeats the
Spiel again
he repeated almost word for word the
very same story to the very same small
group of people and the best part is the
most fitting part for Biden is that it
was not true either time because Donald
Trump did not call neo-nazis very fine
people at Charlottesville he
specifically said I'm not talking about
neo-nazis I'm not talking about white
supremacists they should be condemned
totally but he repeats it Joe Biden
obviously doesn't care one iota about
the truth and that's been true for his
entire career but for most of his career
he was able to get by with the slick
rhetoric of a career politician now
that's beginning to fade and he's just
doing the thing that old people in the
throws of senility do which is repeat
himself this is a a big problem for the
Democrats because you don't nominate Joe
Biden for president because of his
conviction he doesn't have any
convictions that in fact you nominate
Joe Biden for president specifically
because he has no convictions and and he
can be an empty vessel for wherever the
party wants to go you don't nominate a
candidate like Joe Biden for his Youth
and sexiness okay he he gave that up a
little while ago Joe Biden is just the
symbol of
normaly a return to the old ways after
the tempestuous years of trump if Joe
Biden doesn't know what room he's in or
what his name is then the normaly
argument goes
away Joe Biden is a good politician
because he can glad hand and he can
backs slap and he can simper and he can
repeat the talking points that's the
only Talent the man has in politics and
if he can no longer do that then he's
good for nothing if the salt loses its
Savor then it's good for nothing and
needs to be thrown out and trot
underfoot which is why Democrats are
beginning to look for Alternatives and
the window is closing I mean if someone
really wants to make a move for the 2024
race in either the Republican camp or
the Democrat camp they're going to have
to do it within about 5 weeks or
so but certain candidates are beginning
to position themselves to do that boy
what a great clip that was
now make sure that you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael nlls podcast
we'll see you next time